you posted just recently and I I read
everything you post because I'm a creep
you posted about a dream you had about
Dwayne the rock Johnson and I wanted to
ask you about it what's going on with
you and Dwayne the rock Johnson nah this
is a dream right yeah
yeah I mean it didn't feel like it
so that was what's a little worrying but
I was a good dream yeah it's all like a
sex dream I don't get weird it was like
you know you have a love dream
thank you wake up feeling I don't know
they're way more powerful than a sex
dream it's it's you wake up feeling like
sex like moods brief I love it if I woke
up in love with him and I I've had a few
of them over the years and I remember
every single one they last for like a
long time like I'll always have whether
I meet him ever or not I'll always have
feelings for him wait a minute you wane
the rock Johnson and you really do feel
you wake up for these dreams and you
feel like you're actually there so I can
what happens in the dream where you're
in love with him it was a long dream
like I also halfway through it woke up I
went to the bathroom and it came back to
it like sometimes that doesn't happen
but I was able to get right back to it
and we were at like lunch somewhere it's
kind of noisy and it was very flirty and
he leaned over and he whispered I love
you and I pretended not to hear because
I was like I don't know you and at least
my subconscious knew that right I
shouldn't be too forward about to say it
back but I woke up feeling such regret
that I didn't say it back that I felt
like the only thing I could do to remedy
that like wait was to Instagram about it
she instagrammed about it now January
you are a well-known celebrity did you
not hear from Dwayne the rock Johnson
has anyone from his camp reached out to
you I mean you put yourself out there
and said I'm now in love with Dwayne the
rock Johnson and nothing you've heard
nothing back I mean no not yet you're in
a very vulnerable position yeah you're
very vulnerable right now have you
dreamed about anyone else and maybe
anyone who's here now have any
no but I know what you think pass this
pouch January once you get past the
couch and then you start looking at the
band and you know people no camera for
ya
no no no I I can remember almost like in
my between my 20s and 30s pain manny lat
as long time manning was a long feeling
like a lot like good few years I felt
feelings turn one that was oh one I had
to look up like I could see his face and
here's why I didn't know who it was and
it was the guy who was the brother and
face off you know that Alessandro guy
very handsome but I don't know I had no
it was was that you have a name Nivola
yes yeah I don't I give him my best and
he and then the weirdest one was and
this is creepy a little bit but it was
Harry Potter but it was the character in
the book he's a child
he's a little boy it was like book eight
or seven and I was he's still a child
that's inappropriate no he's a teenager
it was fine I'm sure it wasn't I don't
know how to explain this it wasn't the
actor Daniel Radcliffe it was my mental
subconscious version of Harry Potter
when I was reading the book okay so he
was very mature that's really cool yeah
yeah cool I think you're in a lot of
trouble now I'll be honest with you and
these are let's be clear these are not
sex dreams and what I found interesting
is that you said you've had sex streams
and they're uninteresting
whereas I find sex streams to be
absolutely fascinating because there's
many layers of what's happening in my my
love dreams it's not just the layers to
my sex dreams
my sex dreams are pretty intense tell us
about who you've had sex treatment oh
there are so many people in there it's
hard to keep track Harry Potter looks
like a Roman orgy no Harry Potter is not
in there it's like a Disney ride must be
this tall
[Applause]
I bet Hermione was in there like she's a
child
not anymore put the headset alike which
what you're going with this no Gary
older actresses in their 60s are in
there in her 70s
she's trying to pimp out people into
your sex right now you're trying to get
Hermione into my sex dream
just stay keep her out of there okay
yeah it's all the Golden Girls all right
you